I love this question I love it to be
it's because it doesn't fit into the
photos it doesn't fit into the folder
and yet it clearly deals with concepts
that we're supposed to understand so the
question is or do we understand them
okay so let me ask me this what does it
mean for high power should be material
like what defines my clothes today right
they tell you what's at right-angles the
ugly the absent so I need to understand
something about the asymptotes of this
and now what are they we need to prove
that there is rectangular okay so how do
I go about doing them well how do I go
about doing it here
how do i arrived at the asymptotes in
this case good okay so you saw I had to
go through all this algebras but it
wasn't like kusa just for the lawls like
I always try to get to something that I
could apply a limit to right what what
is the subject and I have ISM [ __ ] you
max relation of it then I could say well
as X approached it from you know what's
gonna happen now that really tells you
one piece of the puzzle when you have a
look at this because let's try it out is
it equation I can make one subject that
it's not difficult at all okay I guess I
need to get all the Y's on one side and
everything else over the other side
yes so let's do that I see two terms
with wine and two turns without so let's
just chop it up okay this
are you happy with that it looks okay
nothing too dramatic at that point for
me now in order to make why the subject
to disentangle it from all that other
excursions there right I clearly need to
factorize it right now just stop
remember what we've done so far
I have rearranged some terms anybody I'm
about to factorize like this is not
rocket science but the point is I know
to do this if I conceptually understand
the direction of going in the algebra
looks completely different versus what I
was doing but I'm going towards the same
goal
do you understand but do you see how
this is testing conceptual understanding
versus oh but where is my plus tomatoes
these little cluster planets there's
nothing squared right it's the same
process but wearing very different so
what about he is just one step away
via Y is a function of it actually in
fact it is a bunch of X this guy is not
just a right area however it's also a
function there's what 21 what's the
point of making wonder subject why do I
do that yes
so finding it one step back how do I
find the answer to this I take the limit
as X approaches infinity right so as X
approaches infinity you have a look at
these four terms that you've got over
here do we agree this to this minus 1
become insignificant they become trivial
because when you compare the two a pity
I can't think of it you have three lots
of some enormous number / - lots of the
same enormous number so clearly you have
a ratio happy right you just get three
on two it's just the costume like three
billion or two billion is about three or
two and every Google on to Google is
about three or two well I mean it's
about because of these little things
so now I know I have this sexy person
from Ukraine
this is a horizontal asymptote is it
dawn why he was 302 so now because my
point is to graph this was okay so now
I've got one essence but of course it's
rectangular means you need to know birth
a certain okay that's all right just
come back come back and instead of
making white subject to find a
horizontal asymptote you make X the
subject and after almost an identical
sort of rearrangement you're going to
get a very very similar fraction in fact
you're going to get this you just look
at unless you would like me to give you
zero all right now the moment there
right what I do this what's the point
what's the point what I do that I take
the limit the limit as X approaches as Y
approaches infinity right is X is equal
to come on tell me
it's 1 1 / - it's a half that's a
vertical widest it's this and it looks
to me like they're English